bis sie herr dobrindt haben da eine
gewaltige verantwortung ja mit der
bundesregierung auf sich geladen wenn
sie jetzt so viele von steuergeld und
unter dem einsatz der deutschen soldaten
eingeflogen haben die sich eben als
straftäter entpuppen sozusagen aber ich
finde jetzt das eine gewaltige
überspitzung jetzt drinnen die ich
zumindestens jetzt nicht bestätigt das
sind jetzt gewalttäter identifiziert
worden die hätten nicht in diesen
flieger sein dürfen der überzeugung bin
ich auch wenn man es aber gerade noch
mal geklärt wie die situation war das
ist eine große bereitschaft gegeben hat
zu sagen in dieser phase da vor ort kann
man die papiere nicht überprüfen man
muss sie an einer anderen stelle
überprüfen aber jetzt zu dem ergebnis zu
kommen wie sie es gerade genannt haben
es sind mehr schwerverbrecher nach
deutschland gekommen als ortskräfte
verbrechen habe das nicht gesagt dass
straftäter haben sie gesagt aber das ist
ja im prinzip meinen sie dass damit und
aber das sagen wie aktuell die zahlen
die wir aus dem aus dem bundesland der
ortskräfte ist ein ganz leben gering und
es sind mehrere verbundenheit ich kann
dass es tut mir echt leid das wir haben
wir haben jedoch ist eine überspitzung
wir haben jetzt mehrere tausend
ortskräfte nach deutschland geholt
berechtigterweise die straftäter gehören
hier nicht her und mit diesen
straftätern muss man entsprechend auch
um geben keine frage wiederholen darf
sich das nicht es geht nur noch um einen
geordneten verfahren daraus muss man
jetzt lernen hätten sie gern ein signal
dass das endlich wieder die wollen ja
ich finde es auch sehr wichtig weil
schon wieder die forderungen kommen dass
man jetzt an der stelle doch sehr
schnell dafür schauen muss dass jeder
der irgendwie in afghanistan die chance
hat an die grenze zu kommen diese grenze
zu bescheiden im nachbarland zu sein ist
eine chance hat nach deutschland zu
kommen nein genau das darf eben nicht
passieren also zunächst einmal bei der
rettungsaktion kabel darüber reden wir
jetzt so gern hat 64 aus kräfte
ausgeflogen worden ich weiß nicht wie
viele potentielle kriminelle aber das
ministerium von einer niederen niedrigen
dreistelligen art punkt schon
1908 und java sei wir müssen jetzt nicht
das was das eineinhalb jahren doch das
gehört auch ein
wenig
und wir haben auch gesagt dass es diese
flieger dass das ist ja jetzt die
unterstellung die ein bisschen im raum
steht von ihnen der job und dass wir
diese flüge gar nicht hätten sehen
wollen wir haben auch mehrere tausend
afghanen ausgeflogen die keine
kriminellen wir keine streiks sofern
exakt das was genau gegenüber spielt
zwar sie überspannt die rettungsmission
schon ein erfolg aber das was
ursprünglich angedacht war wir holen die
ortskräfte familien raus ist komplett
gescheitert sieht einfach daran dass
viele oscars wissen wir von den von der
bundeswehr angehören die sich darum
gekümmert hat von lindsay viele
ausgereifte gar nicht mehr die chance
hatten zum flughafen zu kommen das hätte
man
früher tatsächlich organisieren müssen
auch euren organisieren können und das
ist das versäumnis dass wir aufarbeiten
müssen da schieben momentan die
verschiedenen ministerien ihrer
verantwortung hin und her das kannst du
das weiß ich habe gesagt ja das stimmt
ich habe übrigens wir alle haben ein
größeres interesse daran dass die
aufklärung stattfindet auch wir wollen
wissen was an informationen war da nicht
zur verfügung gestanden würde falsch
interpretiert wurde nicht weitergegeben
wurde nicht zur kenntnis genommen oder
man hat eine andere interpretation an
den tag gelegt aufgrund anderer
informationen das muss geklärt werden da
bin ich sehr dafür dass wird auch in
einem neuen deutschen bundestag geklärt
ich will auch wissen was der
bundesaußenminister an dieser stelle
gewusst hat welche informationen er
nicht wahrgenommen nicht weiter falsch
interpretiert hat
[Musik]